- Good morning Believe
Nation, today's message
is make your presence count.
Over to you Trey Songz.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entpresso keep me going
- There was a point
where I was putting out
a new song every week.
It was, Trey Songz music
Monday, I put out a new song
every Monday for like
two and a half months.
Before my mix tape came out,
which was Anticipation, which got
50,000 downloads the first night.
Ready came out.
Ready's had six or seven singles
I think that has a lot to do with it.
Going on tour with Jay-Z,
who's an international superstar.
That definitely brings a
lot of attention to my name.
I performed with Stevie
Wonder on the BET Honors.
I kissed Toni Braxton on stage.
It was a lot of steps
toward where I am now
and I think that it's
just beginning even still.
That's why this run is so
jam packed, my schedule.
That's why I'm in a
different country everyday
cause I need to make my presence felt
and even when I come back next time
I'll work even harder
to make my presence felt
because I'm working here
this time like I'm a new act.
My manager told me we gon'
come out here and we gon
act like it's 2005 and what that means is
act like I just got to make it.
So, I don't feel as though
I'm a superstar here yet.
I'm working my way there.
- So one of my personal goals is to
wherever I go that my presence is felt.
I want to make sure that the
thing I'm spending my time on
has an impact.
I'm heavily driven by impact.
And it's not from an ego point of view,
not that when I walk into a room
you need to worship me,
that's not the goal,
but wherever I'm spending my time
that things are going to get better.
That if I'm spending my
time in this business
this business is going to get better
and it's going to help the community.
If I'm spending time making videos for you
that you are digesting them
and using them and helping them
to make you get better and
build awesome businesses
that impact our culture.
It's the goal.
If I felt like these videos were not
having an impact on you then
I would stop making them.
I would still consume them for myself
cause the number of
habits that I've picked up
that it wasn't having
an impact on you guys
but has an impact on me so I
just keep doing it for myself.
I look at the morning
gratitude series as an example.
I had a youtube series where everyday
I went on and shared three
things I was grateful for
and encouraged you guys to
come on and do it with me.
And we had a good loyal
audience coming and doing it
but it wasn't having an impact I wanted
and so I cut the series.
I still do it personally
every morning with my wife,
but I don't share it with you guys
because I want to make
sure that the things
that I'm spending my
time on is worth while.
I think everybody should have the opinion
that wherever you walk into,
whatever room you're in,
whatever business you're in,
you're going to make it better.
It's your goal to make it better.
Again, not from and ego point of view,
that I'm amazing and I'm going to do this,
but from a genuine desire
to make things better,
to help people, to elevate, to lift.
If you are not making things better,
you're either making things worse,
which isn't great,
or you're just apathetic
and is that the life
that you want to live?
Do you want to walk around
going into all these rooms
and the rooms are your
life, your business,
your friends, these different rooms
of you daily existence and just be
apathetic and not really
caring what happens?
Where if you go in with the intention of
my time matters, my life here is limited,
I want to make every second count.
It shifts your perspective
and I think it's really important.
One of the things I do on
a fairly consistent basis
is look at my schedule.
I look at where am I spending my time.
I live and die by my calendar.
Where am I spending my time
is the most precious asset that I have,
I'm never getting it back,
Where am I spending it?
And doing a constant audit of
are these the right places?
Should I still be making youtube videos?
Should I invest that time to go off
and do something else, or not?
And the things that always
tips the balance for me
is are these things leading
to a major impact or not?
My goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs.
Whether I reach that goal
or not it doesn't matter.
It's the process, it's
the work that I'm doing
has to have the potential to
help a billion entrepreneurs.
If it does, I'm into it.
If it's not, I'm not going to do it.
And I encourage you to value your time
more preciously and to do a severe audit
to look at where you're spending you time
and are you having a positive
impact on your customers,
on your suppliers, on your
friends, on your relationships,
and everybody around you.
Make your time count.
So the question today is I'm curious
what are you spending time on
that you probably shouldn't?
That's not really having an impact,
that you're not making your presence felt,
where are you wasting your time
that you want to change in
your life or your business?
Leave it in the comments below
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Ibby Hadeed
thank you so much Ibby
for picking up a copy
of my book "Your One
Word" it really really
means a lot to me and I really hope
you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you guys
again tomorrow morning for
another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I always tell people the
biggest benefit to my career
was probably in the beginning of things,
I hated the most, like how long it took me
to get to where I feel was
where I was getting my just due.
My first album came of course at the crib
it's going crazy just
got to make it got to go
and wonder woman everything.
And our nucleus on the East Coast,
but I wasn't as successful
as I wanted to be
for a very long time, but the older I get
the more I appreciated that process
that learning curve.
The ability to grow gradually so
I didn't have to learn
everything in front of everybody.
I didn't get catapulted
immediately into success.
That gave me appreciation
for the journey to get
to success, it gave me
appreciation, it made me work hard.
That's why I work this
hard as I do now today
cause I feel like if
"Got to make it" would've
billboard chart topper
success, my first single ever,
I don't think I'd have
the same work ethic,
just be honored.
I love to do music so I'll always rap.
The funny thing about
it is when I was rappin'
and singing it was
something out of this world.
Oh he's going to sing and rap?
But he's an R&B singer.
And the beauty I love about music nowadays
is that you have artists that
almost everybody do both.
I think that's a great part
of the evolution of music
is artists being creative
and believing in themselves
no matter what box that
people try to put 'em in.
Cause no matter what you
trying to do with your life
other people going to try
to put you in this box,
so you got to push through.
- But I'm not in it just for the money,
you know the cars, cars,
clothes, hoes, I suppose.
And that's the tricky
thing about that song
when I say I suppose it's kind
of like thinking in hindsight,
it that really what success is?
No it's not.
That's what success is perceived to be
and what we're taught that it is
through the TV, through movies,
through videos, etcetera.
But success is really what
makes you happy in your heart.
Making music makes me happy.